[Music]
Kylie Jenner maybe a 22 year old
billionaire but turns out quarantine
Kylie is hello relatable it's fun
the reality star was spotted paying a
visit to her pal Stassi in Beverly Hills
on Sunday looking almost unrecognizable
yep
that's the beauty mogul makeup free hair
pulled back in a messy bun smiling at
the camera while rockin tie-dyed
sweatpants and holding salt and vinegar
chips we really should just call this
the universal quarantine uniform I feel
you girl anyway back to all-natural
Kylie no makeup no extensions sweatpants
junk food this is literally me 24/7
under quarantine the only difference is
that Kylie's of Murray sweatpants cost
790 dollars well I got mine on Amazon
for 15 anyway kylie is a fresh-faced
beauty thank you but this natural look
is a far cry from her usual day-to-day
glam this is such a good time to just
take your hair out and your nails out no
lashes no lashes
where did Naturals mean we're so while
she's been staying at home amid the
corona virus pandemic she's been showing
off a more subtle look on social media
ditching her waist length extensions and
showing off her real hair my skin great
I'm going on a hair health journey but
the whole quarantine I'm trying not to
use heat I'm doing masks every other day
a lot of argan oil and these other masks
that I have and the all-natural outing
comes just weeks after kylie urged her
171 million followers on social media to
stay inside in order to help contain the
spread of the virus guys happy self
quarantine I know I've already been
doing my daily reminders about how
important it is right now to practice
social distancing and self-quarantine
I'm going on my ninth day the
coronavirus is a real thing during her
self isolation the Kylie cosmetics
founder has been doing all the things
she said she normally doesn't have time
for okay I'm very excited because I have
my own how cute is this I'm so happy
quarantine has me doing a lot of I
wouldn't normally do but I've always
wanted a garden yep
Kylie's got a green thumb guys over here
and she's also putting her haters on
blast I'm having fun yeah Kylie claps
back at some body shamers online who
recently said she looked better before
giving birth to her daughter stormy in
2018 rude when one person commented on a
throwback video of Kylie at an event in
2017 writing wow she's so skinny here
and another responded saying she was
better
Kylie dropped the freaking mic saying I
birthed a baby you pushed a baby there
at every
[Music]